c'est le fournisseur de l'armée
française et il est yvelinois le groupe
nexter basés à satory participent à la
fabrication des engins de l'armée de
terre il fournit aussi les munitions de
la marine nationale pour euronaval il
vient présenter sa nouveauté le rapid
fire une tourelle équipé d'un canon
télescoper de 40 millimètres fabriqué
avec l'entreprise thalès et bea systems
destinés aux navires et à la une le
problème de la piraterie
le problème des drones aujourd'hui c'est
ces bâtiments sont attaqués par les
zodiac et pour répondre à ces menaces
ces menaces asymétriques on a besoin
d'avoir des canons de ce type là qui
permette véritablement de cibler et de
protéger les navires de guerre mais
surtout les navires de logistique de
l'armée française avec atos aux
clayes-sous-bois d'alès à elancourt ou
encore airbus saint quentin en yvelines
est représenté dans le domaine naval le
géant européen de l'aéronautique possède
notamment des services d'imagerie
satellite conçu en partie sur le site
élan courtois est une activité autour de
l'imagerie satellite qui permet d'aller
dans des zones éloignées regarder ce qui
se passe se détecte et de la pollution
de détecter
des problèmes de trafic
des transports de drogue
il a égalé dette était très très
rapidement et on peut très bien à partir
des images satellites à les observer
quelque part une zone à côté des grands
groupes il ya aussi des pme comme sierra
packaging basée à buc avec deux millions
de chiffre d'affaires par an cette
entreprise est spécialisée dans la
découpe de mousse pour le transport
d'armes de radio ou de matériel
électronique de l'armée française n'a
mis deux types de mousses une qui est
basse densité pour venir absorber les
vibrations une qui est haute densité
pour venir protéger la maquette les
contraintes du client on a besoin de les
comprendre pour savoir si c'est lourd 6
a besoin d'avoir une mousse anti
statique 6 a besoin d'avoir une mousse
retardant au feu et en fait on vient
usines et tout sur place on a notre
stock de mousser en usine tout a vécu
euronaval une opportunité pour ces
entreprises de rencontrer de nouveaux
partenaires
l'industrie navale de défense représente
près de 45 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires dans le monde